what's going on reject nation welcome to
part two of our reaction to falcon and
winter soldier if you missed part one
there's a link in the description box
and pin comment there's also a card up
above us why the heck not full length
reaction watch along where you sync up
with the time code for falconry social
over at our patreon page thank you to
eric over at nerdcon for editing these
highlights anywho
enjoy the reaction and our very lengthy
[Music]
review
this is nuts he's freaking working with
this dude
drop your weapon carly
i'm disappointed in you
[Music]
that's what i was gonna say i took you
in
gave you an opportunity and you betrayed
me because you wanted to control a world
that hurt you
you just want me because you need your
muscle back without a super soldiers how
much power does the power broker really
have
[Music]
so you're the power broker i hired back
truck to spy on me
carly you know i'm always prepared get
out my way no one saw this coming
no nobody on the internet theory
four titles
oh
gotta be wearing a bulletproof vest
right or some come on now
that's a risky move oh but but maybe
she's
she knew
ah it's kind of like winter soldier yeah
yeah that's this very steve thing to do
it's like a lot of
captain america winter soldier yeah
mercy bear is richer fruit than strict
justice
it's a great app thank you oh
i wish that's on the scene where they
were like we got to download this app
how did we work it are we going to just
sign in with google
what means my facebook i don't have this
great man great quote said
wow i did not see any of that coming no
i didn't
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
i'm sorry
[Music]
hmm
your peacekeeping troops carrying
weapons are forcing millions of people
into settlements around the world right
these labels terrorist refugee thug
they're often used to get around the
question why those settlements
yeah that's a good call i get it
but you have no idea how complicated
this situation
is we finally have a common struggle now
think about that now you know how did it
feel to be helpless this isn't about
easy decisions senator you just don't
understand
i'm a black man carrying the stars and
stripes
what don't i understand every time i
pick this thing up
i know there are millions of people out
there who are going to hate me for it
even now here i feel it
and there's nothing i can do to change
yet i'm still here no super cereal
no blonde hair or blue eyes
[Music]
the only power i have is that i believe
we can do better
you control the banks [ __ ] you can move
borders
you can knock down a forest with the
email you can feed a million people
but the question is who's in a room with
you when you're making those decisions
i mean this girl died trying to stop you
and no one has stopped for one second to
ask why
people believed in her cause so much
that they helped her defy the strongest
governments
in the world look you people have just
as much power
as an insane god
or a misguided teenager how are you
gonna use it
[Music]
sorry i was uh i was texting and so all
i heard was uh the black guys
hell yeah so we got eyes on the last
flag smasher that fell into the hudson
he's hurt but not down can you help
always
reporters felt like out of a comic book
panel oh yeah
i really liked dancing a lot one world
one people
oh damn damn you you
see a smile
oh man
the raft oh here we go thunderbolts
where yet
who just this week had announced changes
in their overall policies
of repatriation and resettlement looks
like our friend
zemo kind of got the last laugh
couldn't have worked better if i planned
it myself
oh well maybe i did no i'm kidding i
didn't
or did i you're my festow
walker my god let's go
huh now this
damn you're like a us agent man
we're not gonna need a captain america
we're gonna need a u.s
agent
little duval don't call me that copy
just in your head
thank you oh i'm just glad why russell
gets a good tiara i know
oh here it is
hey what are you doing here i have to
tell you something
about your son he was murdered
what
and that was me
why i didn't have a choice
[Music]
hell yeah you learn to learn to like
therapists
i ain't gonna lie you're special
i mean you ain't no malcolm martin
man no argument there black captain
america huh
damn right
hell yeah we built this country
bled for it i'm not gonna let anybody
tell me i can't fight for it
[ __ ] i almost bought that
man do you ever lighten up nope
oh he's bonding his body would say
all right dude something i want to show
you
no way oh no way
is he is he repairing the history
oh did they really
sam really
i got a statue in a monument
[Music]
[Music]
now they'll never forget what you do for
this country
[Music]
hell yeah so [ __ ] man
didn't be sure
captain america the winner
yes
very nice transition is the show renamed
now
i guess season two that's what season
two is gonna be
oh damn that's c2 gonna be
they talked about how they might do one
especially for captain america type
stories i mean it does
it does make sense to do it this way i
feel like
i i just want to i want to get at least
something where you got
uh anthony mackie up there his cap on
the big screen absolutely
i feel that or on the movie version of a
disney plus
early access release 30 bucks
[Laughter]
i'd like to offer you and your family
our sincerest
the carter name has always been
synonymous with service
trust thank you senator one thousand
dollars
welcome home agent carter
oh my
double agent carter
slightly sinister smirk
super soldiers might be off the menu but
we're about to have full access
to government secrets prototype weapons
you name it
oh god right under your nose
okay all right so we didn't recognize
him at first
that it is it's osnick or eisnik eznick
i think
i don't know how to do the oe
pronunciation uh
and that is the man is featured in uh
zemo dance episode the power broker
episode
zemo's faithful butler didn't recognize
him at first so then yeah zemo did
kill them all off okay got it cool well
i thought this was a pretty satisfying
finale yeah
like for the story it's set out to tell
there's exciting moments undoubtedly
there's some
very moving moments there's nothing here
i'd be like that was so
shocking or nothing was really
surprising right down to sherry carter
it was like oh wow it seems so obvious
that i never thought of beer
yeah yeah yeah it's interesting to kind
of think about you know this is the
second of these
marvel disney plus series that we've
gotten and i appreciate
in this breath the same time i'm sort of
processing how they're different
i appreciate that yeah one division had
this steady build of like crazy
revelation
after crazy revelation what is it going
to turn into by the end
whereas this is very steady and it does
kind of
lay all of its pieces out for you and it
lets them develop slowly as the season
goes on and so i
appreciated this more gradual arc too
yeah like a season finale that has
some surprises or revelations but that
isn't
so much about that or doesn't feel as
much like it's about that it's mostly
like oh man how is this ultimate
conflict we've been building
to gonna finally come to some resolution
you know well they concluded
the story with the story that they set
out to tell the characters all had their
arcs
right down to even john walker oh and i
appreciated how gray
that got very gray almost to the point
where i'm like dude
something to get pretty cool with him
did you just forgive him because
surprisingly
he jumped in and helped out and you know
he helped that one time he's all right
he's a good man he's good now
we're not even gonna ask him about the
shield that sam has now i guess he's
just gonna keep that
i mean all things considered like he
made a mistake he killed the man
none of that is excusable despite what
some people in the comments might say he
made a mistake but before that
there's nothing really there that like
exhibiting him as like a bad person
as a bad guy he made a mistake but i
still do think there was a little bit of
a missing
moment or scene other than a nod or two
i think
there should have been some type of
conversation there's some like ominous
looks that are given in the end
especially during sam's speech at the
very end
but yeah i was a little surprised by
that but at the same time you know yeah
i do start feeling bad for the guy
like when he shows up with his channel
that like the post credits you know the
last one he's like building his shield
oh no it's gonna be bad
i know right level some scores
he shows up you're like oh here it is
here it is that he just starts throwing
his shield and you're like actually
doing it i didn't know but i
it is strange his ass kicked
and they pile on him and i mean in that
moment you can see
kind of both what made him a good
candidate and what made him ultimately
the wrong candidate because he has this
sort of
gung-ho he just jumps right in and it
seems like when he's full on captain
america he
he seems to be less good at decision
making than i would assume he was to get
to the point he's at because yeah he
seems to just sort of rush in and
just kind of brawl with everybody and
then they start just dog piling on him
well he had a change of heart though
there's a moment a changing character
when he had the decision to
be a hero or seek revenge
and he chose to be a hero and the flag
smashers were like get in there
yeah yeah
this was what we wanted you to do he's
leaving you alone
yeah but i'm happy to see that he you
know he gets the ark into
u.s agent they have to be setting him up
for like a sequel
or not like a c but like i i'm assuming
they're making another season they gotta
be at this point you know
and uh to see what his character would
become i guess what
surprised me was how much of like a
softer
positive note it ended for john walker
it was like
yeah all right i'm doing it again
i'm back i'm back he's like rudy on the
football team you know
yeah he had that vibe like back in the
game second shot
all right you know i'll get a new mantle
so much [ __ ] attached to it
that's the mood exactly we're striking
here with his journey but i enjoyed it
you know i still enjoyed it
oh yeah absolutely i mean he i'm glad
that he will at least have
more opportunities to grow and develop
this character because you know for as
much
debate as there has been about john
walker his decisions etc like
yeah wyatt russell's just done such a
great job and i do appreciate them
taking at least a
human approach to that character and
that was probably one of my favorite
surprises this episode was him joining
the fight it being kind of a brawl at
first and then yeah him having that
opportunity
to make a turn and to actually work with
sam and bucky like he's been trying to
all season
but in a way that suggests that the egos
have sort of been put aside
for just the greater good of the
situation so yeah even though it does
raise some questions for me like what is
his status in the world right now
especially with like these officials who
you know the people
don't seem to acknowledge at all yeah
and it's weird because the last time you
started walking around
yeah yeah like weren't you the guy we
just discharged
yeah dishonorably yeah i wanted you to
bring that shield back the guy had a
national televised moment
you're losing the captain america you're
just walking around your captain
american suit
what the hell is going on it's funny
because the previous episode i think was
the longest one of the season and it's
longer than this one at least by the run
times and
it was an episode this one where i felt
like they could have maybe used an extra
10
or 15 minutes to flesh some of those
things out because while i do appreciate
them leaving certain things
in little nods and whatnot say between
walker and sam or whatever
yeah it would have been nice to get a
couple more scenes or a couple expanded
scenes especially
oddly enough in the later parts of the
episode where they are wrapping things
up like i thought the most important
things got the time they deserve but
you know there are certain arcs that
could have gotten more like who like uh
i think like they could have uh expanded
a little bit on even the scene with
bucky
and uh definitely the truck yeah i am
that's the one that's what i was like
you just died unceremoniously
yeah he's like my favorite character he
was like oh wow i was so excited they
brought him back from which was older
i'm still chewing on the execution but
like the scene at the end with bucky and
i forget the the old man's name but the
old man
who he goes and finally confesses to it
was a very
impactful scene and a very heartfelt
scene and i definitely i think i teared
up during that scene too
but i was also kind of surprised at the
abruptness and i liked that they sort of
made it a two-part thing where he has
his direct confrontation
and then he goes and sees what he's you
know doing to cope afterwards but
that was another thing where i was like
huh because this was such a a
lived-in element in the first half and
it definitely gets
tied up here but i don't know it just
felt like something that could have
maybe
used a little bit more breathing room or
a little more catharsis or something
it was edited quickly yeah yeah it was
edited quickly and
i did wish there was more in that i do
like a little bit more of the visual
language to it of how you're not relying
on the dialogue here but you kind of
just
go into like the middle of that like he
walks in and then you just hop
into like the middle of that
conversation and that confession and
then you see like a look of the old man
and then it just kind of cuts away
and it's like you do get that moment
where he's um observing him
and the girl he went on the date with in
the restaurant which was nice and
pleasant you're still seeing that man's
able to
look like he's able to enjoy himself
still even though now he knows
because now he knows the truth so you're
gonna get closure yeah you're getting
this sense of closure for both of these
characters and you see
even bucky going back to sam's family
and then having just a great old martin
riggs time with him
yeah and not hitting on sarah he's being
real on his best behavior
he's having just a great time there so
you're seeing that he's grown and
learned to open up and that having that
arc
it's like the arcs were present there
for bucky for sure even him
leaving his therapist that thank you
note all the names are crossed off on
the list
there's a lot of beautiful things there
and uh especially with uh i
i thought like yeah bucky's performance
but to me
what i love the most is what they've
done with captain america here
we talked about that in the breakdown of
the last reaction we did of how this has
slowly really been a transitional point
for sam wilson to become captain america
and not only for him but also for the
audience to get there with him
because it could be jarring not because
he's a black man just because he's a
different person
who's uh captain america all of a sudden
yeah and so this is get and this dealt
so much with the transition of a new
captain america right down to john
walker being in the role and then
sam wilson and then by the time sam gets
here you really feel like he's
learned like the sense of shame or
nervousness apprehension that he had at
the beginning of the season
everything that he's encountered from
the conversations with flax smashers to
isaiah bradley it's very natural how he
got to this point where he's willing to
embrace it
and i love how the wakandans are like oh
yeah we're gonna make this look a
[ __ ] american outfit man
we're gonna make this unmistakable this
ain't gonna look
like a bunch of wakanda vibranium this
is good no one's gonna think you're
captain france
or captain uk or any other red white and
black
or something man you look so
as cool america
as fun yeah i guess i was just expecting
like a different suit
overall even though there were like
certain images that people were using
under thumbnails and such
but i think he rocks it well what i
loved so much about what they really
demonstrated here is
you know when he was handed the shield
in uh an end game one of the questions i
did have was like
you know i'm sure he's got the
characteristic character like the inner
character as a human being
to be captain america absolutely but i
kind of feel like steve rogers
relies quite a bit on the fact that he's
got super soldiers here you know
like for a lot of very specific
situations so
here what they showed in this in this
finale was how he can be captain america
without the super soldier sermon yes he
relies on tech but he's also got the
years of skill with his wings
red wing kind of like his little r2d2 in
a certain way all the amount of actual
martial arts he himself knows how to do
all the combat training he has all the
tactical know-how
and then of course like some i'm
assuming there's some vibranium
armor in his suit right there in there
yeah
yeah lord please his head's exposed so
there's gotta be something
i better fill
in fact we're going to cover all the
parts of your face the old one didn't
it's funny when you think about it yeah
i guess we're just going to take the lid
off
it
it's yeah maybe maybe he'll get an
upgrade for uh harsher conditions than
the second one in the second season but
still like the demonstration of the
action scenes would have how he
implemented the shield
too showing a lot with his aerial
maneuvers of how what he's able to do
and then even
working alongside communications with
red wing
but you know like mainly the ability of
his aerial skills the flight
how he implements that with the shield
and how he uses the shield differently
than how we saw steve rogers use it but
it's really the speech that that feels
like out of a comic book panel
absolutely like a very overt direct
it's pointless message it's everything
you wanted to say
is hearing it too like the audience is
getting it it's not just
for the people around them it's being
televised yeah the world's learning like
oh this is our new captain america
they're embracing it because he's saying
all the things that really connect with
people
to me i'm like i could see some people
actually not liking that scene just
because of how i mean a
some political things what did you say
but b
even the the execution how it was
handled can
feel like uh you know like a little
cheesy in the sense of how direct it is
like
but in that situation i'm like i feel
like you'd be direct and that's sort of
the demonstration showing how it's grown
into captain america in this scene
and it does feel like out of a conquer
panel and plus i just love the
cinematography of
so much of this episode especially when
you got like the police lights the red
and blue lights or
law enforcement lights flashing and then
all the close-up shots were just like
the reflection
of that you know yeah it was really like
plugged into the environments like
the the red and blue from the police
lights but also even in the building
when they're in the interior and they've
got the tarps up and it's just all
amber and there's all these shadows and
whatnot like they did a good job too
with the
changes in you know when it was more
steady versus handheld like really
putting you on the ground in those
scenarios and even putting you like in
the van with the hostages with the grc
people
uh to you know really showcase that
peril as well like they really captured
every perspective
of the situation in a way that felt
visceral you know mr rose probably the
the best word for it and i feel like
that was when the episode was
moving at its most natural pace was when
it was doing
those you know dark knight-ish or you
i think name-checked michael mann like
those kinds of like handheld like really
grungy
pov type shots i didn't name check matt
go michael mann during the
reaction i name check michael manning
between the cut and the reaction to the
review
that's a behind-the-scenes look for you
guys this is just saying you know
it's gonna become the most talked about
part of this video when i when i
stole your you said michael mann and
i've been learning every top comment
john said michael mann snow
proof is why you edited the video
so whoa like john great point
you should come on our channel mr sunday
movie says
in the comments oh cool i mean because
of your michael mann
point man i came up with that
independence
and i'll be here like daniel kaluuya and
get out
no yeah just watching me
you're going to be the high on pot noose
kid as well i skyrocket to a life of
fame and fortune off this one michael
mann comparison he's
like well it felt like a crime thriller
at some points
oh yeah absolutely and it definitely hit
the way how
uh christopher nolan has been inspired
by michael mann it's coming and then
yeah that's sort of the five of them
that's the easiest way to make your
comic book police operation feel gritty
it was badass though it was super badass
and uh the most
moving angle of this was the isaiah
bradley moment
like i loved the reaction look when he's
watching him on the news
like [ __ ] man that sam wilson he's he's
making some making some good points man
but
i can't let myself go there i can't
fully give yeah i can't and i love the
back and forth you know what it it it
kind of
made i remember watching like uh a
docu-series uh about
civil rights movement and what the their
chemistry kind of reminded me of
is like a little bit of martin luther
king and
malcolm x with when if they got along
but like that difference of no we we
believe in a lot of the same causes but
our approaches we don't
are really different you know they
started saying like you know you know
malcolm you know martin you know
you're saying all those things and i
thought that was uh that was really
funny but there was a part of my head
that didn't think of that they had their
convictions with a different approach so
like that scene where they're kind of
ripping each other in the backyard like
i thought that was great
and then you got like elijah too who
always opens that door
always has that creating like god damn
it man why are you doing that i hate you
you make my grandpa upset again
gonna rile him up but then he when he
comes outside he's like getting along
with him like hell yeah that's cool the
second they show up at the museum like
oh my god oh he did it oh
he's gonna be remembered he's a part of
the history now
he's not going to be forgotten like
everything that's painful about
isaiah bradley's backstory especially
the forgotten hidden
push down now he gets to be honored and
recognized
remembered it's a part of the captain
america legacy now was
so moving my god oh yeah if i wasn't
wearing
glasses i would let the tears just
stream
like an anime character
or like or more serious anime where it's
like a perfect river
yeah yeah white eyes
perfect yeah and we got them both
if only i could animate these things in
it would be great
that's a wing of the captain america
exhibit that's going to have to keep
being expanded though
because sarah a lot of isaiah bradley is
like at the sets
i yeah sure it's a good start
that was great man but that that speech
that he
back to that speech though it comes down
to the main question that he poses
to them who's in the room when you're
making these decisions
the people you're going to impact or is
it just more people like you and how
much have you considered your
opposition and the perspectives of both
yeah those people that you're
serving but also the people who seek to
oppose you
yeah i loved how he throws the questions
back in their face of
when you are judged or criticized like
these flag smashers these people you
call terrorists and the way hey like
people use
labels like thugs refugees as a way to
really avoid diving into the question
yeah these are points that certain
youtube channels are not going to like
i saw a great tweet the other day that
was like keep your politics out of my
fantasy about
government engineered super soldiers of
war
how can you not i have these spoilers
had a tweet that i just loved that was
uh something about like
youtubers who make thousands of videos a
year talking about politics hate when
their tv show talks about politics
well that's who yeah i'm like whose
entertainment are you providing
anywho those points are are so
palpable and it's that thought process
that
mindset that betterment for the civilian
the betterment for everyone wanting
equality looking at this chance of the
blip as an
opportunity to come together right
now it's different franchise so come
together
with each other like uniting that is
captain america qualities it's not it's
not government publicity
or any of that jazz it's not taking out
your own personal vendettas it's these
characteristics that make a captain
america
yeah and uh that's what was so great
about that speech like
being televised you just see everyone
watching well yeah it's like everybody
from
uh like i love they're coming to like tv
it's like they're showing like yeah i
don't know that everybody in the
vicinity even john walker is like paying
attention to this but also like just
everyone
in the world seems like he's watching
right now they cut to crowds in india
crowds in china people in bars and
people across
the world just watching that one tv it's
it's the stereotypical like at first
they're just made because someone turned
off the soccer game but then pretty soon
they're all like wrapped with attention
and then he walked away and everyone
started cheering around the world
yeah and then everyone became an
american
[Laughter]
yeah that was good stuff too i was
really happy with that scene
yeah and even even the point too about
like the resources like you know you
could pick up the phone and feed a
million people like you know
looking at i think that's another sort
of captain america quality
is looking at what do i have at my
disposal and what's the impact i can
make with
that well that that was the gray part of
this series
overall that i really love like can some
things have been ended better or fleshed
out better
like i'll be honest i don't really care
about carly as much as i hope to care
about carly
like i liked a lot of her scenes i mean
as a matter of fact let me say this
differently i think the actress is
freaking awesome
it's not really carly didn't care about
it's more like i would have liked to get
more into the flag smashers
you know felt more of that loss and
weight and like
really kind of find more myself debating
like maybe the flag smashers are right
you know like push to identify with them
in uncomfortable ways or something yeah
yeah i would have liked some of that
more like a little more provocative
or something but more importantly more
than provocative just making more of an
emotional connection to them
especially when you know she does die
and he carries her
her body out there and he's talking to
the government officials about you can't
call them terrorists
you know i think they just would have
added that much more weight to it
instead of
a lot of times i feel like i'm being
told what the flag smashers do from
other people's perspectives
i don't quite feel like i've just lived
with them as much as i like live with
i feel like i live with the lifestyle of
like sam wilson and his family
yeah more than i have uh like with uh
the flag smashers at all and i think
those moments would have hit better and
i probably would have felt more with
carly's
very predictable getting shot death uh
you know like i would have felt a lot
more for carly i think the the the lead
actress uh who's there forgetting right
now is
brilliant uh i think she's powerful i
just i did feel myself not as impacted
by the character
who's when the flag smashers were like
such a big part of
the debate and political topics the
show's trying to bring up yeah and it's
their ideology that is sort of the
the driving force that's shaking up the
world and causing people to join this
movement or whatever and yeah
it seems like the season overall has
this interesting inversion where
you start off with a lot of character
stuff for sam and bucky and it sort of
gives way to a lot of action in between
with the situation at hand
and when you come back to sam and bucky
and i feel like in that middle portion
we kind of started getting to know carly
and the flag smashers a little better
and then yeah when we
zoom out of that it mostly becomes
action for them at least the past
this episode and the previous um so i've
read some criticism online and i do
think that there is something to it
where it's like
part of the issue marvel seems to have
with some of these more sympathetic
villains is that the sympathy
or at least the attention paid to those
elements in the actual
you know what's on screen starts to wane
the closer you get to act
three yeah where it would probably be
very important to keep those things
um because i mean in the one sense i i
imagine it makes it a lot easier to just
have
action that's easy to root for but at
the same time that's another thing that
you know given an extra 10 15 minutes on
this episode i would have liked
especially because she has these
confrontations with both sam and bucky
at a certain point and they both seem
like they're leading to something
interesting
but they kind of seem like they also
need to move along
yeah pretty quick so yeah could use a
little more meat on that bone
yeah yeah i agree good words thanks good
words you said john dog
back to that gray part though that i was
talking about with captain america
he is so crazy we call him captain
america now it just works he's just
captain america
he's not black falcon anymore as i've
been calling him all these that's right
you are the first one to call him way
back when i know
even during the trailer reaction oh damn
it's black falcon we were seeing winter
soldier in the theaters he leaned over
first five minutes that's black falcon
and that's white captain here
that's black nick fury
[Laughter]
and that's white iron man white hole
you know she's an honorary asian person
and she i've seen that meme going around
all week
her and shanxi sorry
so that trained my mind when he brings
up the problems and telling that he's
like
saying to them the differences they can
make like making the comparison to
the way how people felt uh when a god
made half the earth disappear like push
them out of their homes and such
you guys are about to leave people with
that same exact feeling about the ones
you are pushing out
just because of the blip the gray area
is when he's saying that they pose a
question back to him
and what about the people who blip back
are what what do they go homeless now
like what do they do
you know someone has to be pushed out
basically and and even
sam had a look of damn [ __ ] i don't know
what to do
and that gray area is what i loved yeah
that's where he says well now we got a
common problem
and now let's solve this you know that's
why i love that come together
right now i feel like i said that
earlier i don't know there's so much
happening here we never got a clear
answer to who val is we don't get a
clear answer to what's going on with
sharon carter
she's going to be continuing her power
broker business uh working within the
government
shield went down in flames
and in uh winter soldier and then she
was working on the cia i believe
in captain america civil war so maybe
when they said you gave
job back in your old division maybe val
works in the same division
not likely she's going to be doing her
power broker deals there working within
government
ah corrupt corrupt america hell yeah
so so yeah there's some things you just
don't get uh definitive answers on and
that's where people have
theory videos so watch oh look out now
and then go oh who she who she who she
and they won't take it'll take a long
time to answer that
we didn't see thunderbolt ross like a
lot i really thought we'd see him to me
that didn't seem like a crazy
far-fetched like and i wouldn't be like
losing my [ __ ]
but i i thought we'd see him we thought
we'd get it set up for thunderbolts i
still feel like it's still there
oh let's see if it's there for the young
avengers has been all over this too
you know yeah yeah with isaiah bradley
with isaiah brent
bradley specifically he's gonna be the
younger android
yeah that's nick is gonna be here yeah
he's gonna join the team
we're gonna resurrect howard stark we're
gonna get him on the team
everyone hank pam thank you it's going
to be a blast
everyone has been tased just going to be
part of the
team i like it but yeah no i i do think
that perhaps that is the the nicest
element
of this episode or at least of the
argument that the show makes is is going
back really quick to that point that you
made it earlier about
it feeling like a bit of a comic book
speech that he gives at the end like the
kind of thing you would see in a comic
book that does have a lot on its mind
that does want to comment on the
relevant issues that it's
diving into i feel like what kept that
from
being too much of a fantasy or being
silly is the fact that they put in that
uh yeah that pushback and that that the
moments where they give the senators a
couple
chances to be like whoa this is way
bigger than you understand keep talking
while i'm distractingly doing stuff in
front of you
and for sam to embrace that idea you
know what camera
it is a complicated situation and we
need to dive further in like it is a bit
of a fantasy because there are things
he's saying that i imagine for a lot of
people are just like what you wish you
could grab a senator or somebody with
that level of power and say
all right but yeah they gave it some
credence by the fact that they made it a
debate and not just a soapbox you know
yeah man dude totally paid attention
completely you
were so good at it you were like 30 in
the morning task
it's okay it's all these it's 2 30 in
the morning
somewhere it's 2 30 somewhere
i don't know you know what man i think
you could go longer i think you could go
i think you could do this all day
oh come together right now
justice league oh i could we transfer
this to both people
you could do yeah dude you could put
like 100 emails in there
send it to everyone on our subscriber
list why
i don't know in case they feel like uh
editing videos for us
but yeah i mean i thought this was a
very satisfying dude [ __ ] not talking
about something
i remember i talked about what i wanted
to talk about is something that we
should have talked about that was great
ending
bucky and sam are friends captain
america winter soldier
awesome got red wing back yep it
became a real character like i thought
he would be and
is there anything is there anything um
didn't talk about
it's a lot to remember right now easter
eggs not screw that leave it as someone
else
is there any more political subtext we
can piss people off with
the music was great music looks great
you know they had some pretty distinct
ass music yeah dude i totally think so
too well cool
hey guys i hope you enjoyed this video
me too i i don't take this one right
yeah i'm going to edit this okay good
only like 45 minutes of us
it's only 45. like 30.
[Music]
whoever's here are the few who cared
this is all staying in so guys uh
i love you love you all
and uh here's my phone number and uh
subscribe click the notification bell
thanks eric for editing the highlights
part and
you guys stay classy are we done i think
we're done i think we're so done we've
been done for
45 minutes let's see you guys